Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿De verdad
Rusia tiene un sistema capitalista? Han
pasado 30 años desde la disolución de la Unión
Soviética. De hecho, aquí en VisualPolitik
le hemos dedicado un vídeo. Es decir, Rusia
ha abandonado el comunismo pero… ¿De verdad
podemos decir que Rusia tiene un mercado libre y
capitalista como Estados Unidos o Europa? Es más…
¿Hasta qué punto Rusia ha mejorado con
respecto a como estaba en la época soviética?
Querida comunidad de VisualPolitik,
sé que en los últimos meses,
todo el mundo quiere oír hablar
de la política exterior de Rusia:
sobre todo lo referente a Ucrania. Pero hoy vamos
a adentrarnos en lo que ocurre dentro de Rusia.
Porque, seamos claros, Rusia puede
ser una potencia militar pero,
en lo que bienestar de sus ciudadanos respecta,
este país está muy lejos de entrar en eso que
llamamos el “primer mundo”. Y alguno dirá “¡Hey!
¡Pues yo he estado en Moscú y parecía
una ciudad europea cualquiera!”.
Lo cierto es que Rusia es muy grande. Y fuera
de las grandes capitales podemos encontrarnos
regiones como la República de Karelia, con un
PIB per cápita equivalente al de Libia. O Osetia
del Norte, que podría compararse con un país
africano como Djibouti. Las cifras están ahí:
Rusia es un gigante de recursos naturales. Tienen
gas natural y petróleo. Pero sus ciudadanos ven
muy poco de esta riqueza. De hecho, algunos
se llegan a plantear si no estaban mejor
durante el comunismo. Atentos a lo que llegó
a decir el propio Vladimir Putin al respecto.
(Quien no eche de menos la Unión Soviética,
no tiene corazón. Quien quiere que vuelva,
no tiene cerebro. –Vladimir Putin)
Y respecto al capítulo de “libertad y democracia”
mejor no hablar. Cualquiera que se atreva a hacer
oposición a Putin corre el riesgo de acabar en
la cárcel o incluso morir envenenado. Y si no,
que se lo pregunten a Alexei
Navalny o a tantos activistas.
Pero todo esto ya lo sabéis. Especialmente
si sois miembros veteranos de la comunidad
VisualPolitik. Lo que seguramente no
sepáis es la historia de cómo Rusia ha
llegado hasta aquí. Una historia que tiene dos
protagonistas: BORIS YELTSIN y VLADIMIR PUTIN
¿Y qué significa exactamente
eso del “capitalismo de los
silovikís? Al final del vídeo lo entenderéis todo.
Porque las preguntas que hoy nos hacemos son
¿Por qué ha fracasado la transición de Rusia al
capitalismo? ¿Qué ha hecho Vladimir Putin para
actualmente gobernar Rusia con mano de hierro?
Hoy, vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(LA NUEVA RUSIA)
En septiembre de 1991 se celebró en Moscú uno
de los conciertos más multitudinarios de todos
los tiempos: el Monsters of Rock en Rusia. De
teloneros, la banda local E.S.T.. Luego un cartel
de auténtico ensueño: The Black Crowes, Pantera,
Metallica y AC/DC. Su música había sido censurada
durante años por el régimen comunista. Ahora
estaban tocando allí, en pleno Aeródromo Túshino.
Estaba claro que las cosas
estaban cambiando en Rusia.
Y la figura clave era Boris Yeltsin. En
las primeras elecciones democráticas,
conseguía hacerse con la presidencia de la
República Socialista Soviética de Rusia. Su
papel enfrentándose al golpe de estado que
organizaron el Partido Comunista y la KGB
en agosto de 1991 fue decisivo para que este
alzamiento fracasara. Su imagen subido a un
tanque, dirigiéndose al pueblo en defensa
de la democracia, disparó su popularidad.
(El proceso democrático en el país está
adquiriendo un alcance cada vez más amplio
y un carácter irreversible. Los pueblos de Rusia
se están convirtiendo en dueños de su destino.)
Toda su popularidad, todo su capital político,
lo iba a emplear en acelerar el cambio de una
economía controlada por el Estado a una de
mercado ¿El problema? El problema es que la
transición al capitalismo trae muchos problemas,
sobre todo en el corto plazo. Pensadlo así:
los soviéticos tenían precios controlados.
Prácticamente todos los vienes tenían un
precio estipulado por el estado que, en muchos
casos, era más bajo que el precio de mercado.
De repente, Rusia se abrió al comercio mundial,
con precios libres para todos los bienes ¿Qué
ocurrió? Que los precios de los bienes se
dispararon de un día para otro. Sin embargo,
tanto la mayoría de los sueldos como las
pensiones de los jubilados seguían con las
cifras de la época soviética ¿Conclusión?
Pobreza, alcoholismo y hasta enfermedades
infecciosas. En la memoria de todos
los rusos que han vivido esa época
están esas latas de cangrejo que enviaban
ONGs de Finlandia y otros países vecinos.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque este
no es el único problema! Casi todos
los países ex comunistas también sufrieron
inflación durante los años 90. Sin embargo,
muchos de ellos consiguieron
levantar cabeza porque también
aumentaron la productividad. Ese es el caso
de Polonia o República Checa, por ejemplo.
Sin embargo, la economía rusa se hundió. El
PIB del país cayó a la mitad en pocos años.
Y todo esto se explica, en
parte, por la corrupción.
Yeltsin quería privatizar todas las empresas
estatales. Pero el proceso estaba tan viciado,
que todas esas empresas terminaron en
manos de oligarcas ¿Por qué? Podríamos
decir que fue un proceso muy parecido al de
Ucrania. Si queréis conocerlo con más detalle,
os dejo un vídeo donde lo
explicamos en la descripción.
Pero lo importante es que los rusos cada vez
eran más pobres. Y la popularidad de Yeltsin
cayó hasta tal punto, que en 1993, tan sólo 2
años después de llegar al poder, el Congreso le
quiso poner una moción de censura ¿Y qué creéis
que hizo el bueno de Yeltsin? Pues atentos.
(Yeltsin envía tropas para expulsar
del parlamento a sus rivales armados;
se desata una feroz batalla en la capital)
La Casa Blanca de Moscú, sede del parlamento
ruso, fue bombardeada por los tanques enviados
por Yeltsin. Se produjeron cientos de
muertos. Y así es como Yeltsin se dio
cuenta de que eso de la democracia no es
tan bonito como lo pintan. Días más tarde
redactó una nueva constitución rusa para
evitar que el parlamento le hiciera sombra.
Sin embargo, nadie en Occidente levantó la
voz. En su momento, el por entonces Presidente
de Estados Unidos, Bill Clinton, llegó a
decir esto sobre su homólogo ruso. Atentos.
("Nunca podemos olvidar que Yeltsin borracho es
mejor que la mayoría de las alternativas sobrias",
dijo el presidente Bill Clinton, según el
ex subsecretario de Estado Strobe Talbott.)
Y no, esto no es un estereotipo cultural. Tu
te ibas de fiesta con Yeltsin y volvías sobrio,
porque se bebía su vodka, el
tuyo y el de todos tus amigos.
La política mundial nos ha dado a grandes
alcohólicos que pasarán a la historia,
pero lo de Yeltsin se lleva la palma. Atentos.
(Un Boris Yeltsin borracho
fue encontrado fuera de la
Casa Blanca en calzoncillos tratando de
llamar a un taxi 'porque quería pizza')
Dicho de otra forma: para Occidente, Yeltsin era
un borracho simpático que no daba problemas. Pero
para los rusos, Yeltsin era un borracho que no
era capaz de solucionarlos ¡Y ojo! Porque no
sólo hablamos de problemas económicos.
En 1994, Rusia entró en guerra con los
separatistas Chechenos. En estos momentos,
pensaréis que la situación no podía ir peor.
Pero en ese momento es cuando Boris Yeltsin dijo
“¡Sujétame el vodka!”. Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(DEL COLAPSO A LA CIMA)
En 1995 la situación económica de Rusia seguía
siendo lamentable. Así que el Gobierno de Yeltsin
ideó un nuevo esquema para la segunda ola de
privatizaciones. Hablamos del conocido como
préstamos por acciones. La idea era que los
oligarcas prestaran dinero al Estado ruso a
cambio de hacerse con la gestión de
las empresas estatales más valiosas:
las gasísticas, las petroleras,
etc... Entre. Si el Estado no
devolvía los préstamos a tiempo... esos
préstamos se convertirían en acciones.
¿Qué creéis que ocurrió? ¡Exacto! Los oligarcas
se hicieron con empresas gigantes a precio de
saldo. Por ejemplo, el capo de los
oligarcas rusos, Boris Berezovsky,
se hizo con la petrolera Sibneft, valorada en
3.000 millones de dólares, gracias a un préstamo
de 200 millones de dólares al Estado ruso.
Pero este es sólo un ejemplo. Para el año 1996,
Yeltsin ya se había encargado de crear
una generación de multimillonarios que
le debían favores. Y, creedme, esos
millonarios le devolvieron el favor.
¿Cómo? Con apoyo electoral. En 1996,
Rusia tenía elecciones. Pero la mayoría
de los medios estaban en manos de estos
oligarcas. El principal opositor de Yeltsin
por aquel entonces era un tal GENNADI
ZIUGÁNOV, líder del partido comunista.
Paréntesis: este señor sigue siendo el
líder del partido comunista hoy en día,
que ya han pasado 26 años de
aquellas elecciones. Vamos,
que lo de los liderazgos vitalicios en Rusia
está en todas partes. Fin del paréntesis.
El caso es que los oligarcas apoyaron
a Yeltsin sin paliativos. Y Yeltsin
estaba muy contento ¿Cómo de
contento? Pues así de contento.
¡No me podéis negar que
este hombre era entrañable!
Eran buenos tiempos para Yeltsin y los oligarcas…
pero malos tiempos para Rusia. En 1998
se produjo la crisis financiera rusa,
que ya os contamos con más detalle en
un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción.
La moneda rusa perdió un 70%
de su valor de la noche a la
mañana. Pero la caída del rublo no
se detuvo ahí. En diciembre de 1998
se necesitaban el triple de rublos
que en agosto para obtener un dólar.
Lo bueno amigos es que, como bien sabéis, una
crisis es sinónimo de oportunidad. Una moneda
débil permite a las empresas de un país ganar en
competitividad. Y 1998 fue un punto de inflexión.
La economía rusa revivió y las reformas
económicas de Yeltsin empezaron a dar
resultado. 1999 fue el primer año de una senda
de crecimiento que se extendió hasta que en 2008
estalló a nivel mundial la Gran Recesión.
Entre 1999 y 2008 Rusia tuvo un crecimiento
económico promedio anual del 6,9%. En
esto tuvo bastante que ver el precio
del petróleo. El barril de Brent pasó de
costar 10 dólares a comienzos de 1999,
a rebasar los 50 en 2005 y alcanzar los 140
dólares en el verano de 2008. El que más se
benefició de esta época de bonanza tiene nombre
y apellidos: Vladimir Putin. En agosto de 1999 se
convertía en primer ministro y el 31 de diciembre
en presidente del país. Yeltsin acordó con Putin
el blindaje de su inmunidad y, justo después,
dimitió. Arrancaba una nueva era para Rusia.
(LA ERA
DE LOS SILOVIKÍ)
El crecimiento económico disparó el consumo
en Rusia. Por fin los rusos empezaban a notar
diferencias después de haber dejado atrás
el estancamiento soviético. En un principio
Putin tomó buenas decisiones. Eligió como
principal asesor económico a Andrei Illarionov,
un economista liberal. Su gobierno simplificó y
redujo los impuestos. Utilizó con prudencia los
multimillonarios ingresos que el Estado estaba
obteniendo con el alza del precio del crudo,
cada vez más importante para la economía del
país. Putin culminó muchas de las reformas
concebidas en los años 90, incluida la legislación
para mejorar el sistema judicial. Pero todos los
esfuerzos por reforzar la seguridad jurídica de
Rusia saltaron por los aires con el caso Yukos.
En 2003 Rusia arrestó a Mijaíl Jodorkovski, en
aquel momento el hombre más rico del país gracias
al éxito de Yukos, que se había convertido en
la principal petrolera rusa. Un año después,
Yukos fue desmembrada y sus activos asumidos por
Rosneft, una empresa petrolera perteneciente al
Estado. Condenado por fraude fiscal, Jodorkovski
fue encarcelado en Siberia. Pasó una década en
prisión hasta que fue indultado por Putin.
Desde entonces vive exiliado en Reino Unido.
El caso Yukos fue el comienzo de la guerra
de Putin contra los oligarcas. Atacar a los
oligarcas era una medida muy popular. La gente
sentía que aquellos hombres de negocios se habían
apropiado de las riquezas rusas. El problema es
que Putin no emprendió esta guerra para crear
una economía realmente capitalista donde hubiera
competencia entre empresas. Simplemente cambió
a la vieja casta de oligarcas por otra. De los
amigos de Yeltsin pasamos a los amigos de Putin,
más conocidos como los SILOVIKI.
Y diréis ¿Qué es un siloviki? Pues
es un político o empresario que viene del
ejército o de alguna agencia de seguridad
como el KGB. Recordad que Putin empezó su
carrera como espía de la KGB. Por ejemplo,
una de las empresas más importantes de
Rusia es la petrolera ROSNEFT. Pues bien,
desde el año 2012, su CEO es un tal IGOR
SECHEN, ex expía de la KGB y mano derecha de
Putin durante sus primeros años en el Kremlin.
Soy consciente de que su nombre no os suena de
nada. Pero seguro que su apodo
os dice bastante del personaje.
(Así es como el 'Darth Vader' de Rusia emergió de
las sombras para convertirse en
el zar del petróleo de Putin)
Como estáis viendo, en Rusia impera un
capitalismo de amiguetes. Es la era de
los silovikí. Como sucedía con los emperadores
romanos, el dedo de Putin marca el destino de
los nuevos ricos de Rusia. Cualquiera aventurero
que intente hacer fortuna sabe que puede perder
el favor del Estado si se sale de la línea
oficial, si se vuelve demasiado codicioso o
si sus activos comienzan a parecer demasiado
atractivos a alguno de los silovikí.
Ahí está la historia de Igor Pushkarev.
Propietario de una gran empresa de cemento
en el extremo oriente ruso, Pushkarev se unió
al partido de Putin y en 2008 fue elegido
alcalde de Vladivostok. En 2016 desafió en las
primarias del partido a Vladimir Miklushevsky,
el gobernador regional. Miklushevsky llamó a Putin
y como decimos en VisualPolitik, dicho y hecho.
(El alcalde de Vladivostok, acusado
de corrupción y abuso de poder)
Pero, sin duda alguna, la historia que
explica mejor la economía rusa es la
de VLADIMIR YEVTUSHENKOV. Este buen
señor es el propietario de Sistema,
una empresa de inversiones. En 2009 Sistema
compró por 2.500 millones de dólares una
participación de control en Bashneft. Bashneft
era una petrolera de tamaño medio. Pero la
compañía creció rápidamente y se convirtió en
uno de los mayores productores de derivados del
petróleo gracias a sus refinerías ¿Qué creéis
que pasó? En 2014 Vladimir fue arrestado.
El verdadero motivo de su arresto fue que se
negaba a vender esta petrolera al gigante Rosneft,
cuyo CEO es el amigo de Putin ¿Cuándo
le sacaron de la cárcel? Cuando aceptó
la venta a cambio de 5.200 millones
de dólares más una indemnización de
2000 millones. Años más tarde, el bueno
de Vladimir ya ha aprendido la lección.
(El Estado tiene el derecho de tomar cualquier
decisión, les guste o no a las empresas... Puede
haber algunas consecuencias desagradables para
alguien; las hubo para nosotros. Pero así es la
vida. Los negocios deben trabajar por el bien del
Estado. Tan pronto como se pierde de vista eso,
siempre sucede algo desagradable. Vladímir
Yevtushenkov (Financial Times, 2021)
Rusia ha enfocado la modernización de su
economía como una cuestión de tecnología
y no como una estrategia de apertura a
los mercados internacionales y seguridad
jurídica. Que se haya convertido
en un régimen autoritario tampoco
ayuda. Y la política exterior de Rusia
tampoco está ayudando con la economía.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que Putin
será sucedido por alguno de los silovikí?
¿O pensáis que pasará igual que con
la URSS y llegara un momento en el
que este sistema colapse? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios. Y,
por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas. Así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!